(pensive music)
- Everyone thinks of Wyoming,
it's the cowboy state,
so you think of open
land, cattle and cowboys.
They want it to be open land, cattle,
cowboys and crypto.
- [Narrator] This 40-acre plot of land
in northwestern Wyoming has a new owner,
a group of around 6,000 crypto investors
whose goal is to build a city
using the Ethereum blockchain.
- We're imagining this kind of future
where you see this beautiful parcel map
of all the different pieces of land.
In one click, basically
you just buy this NFT
and you now have the
right to use that land.
- [Narrator] This group of
investors is called CityDAO
and it has no official leader.
Rather, it's owned and
governed by its members.
- We are collectively governing this land,
so we're deciding what
happens to the land.
If we're going to build things,
if we're gonna allow
people to camp on the land.
- [Narrator] This type of organization
is known as a DAO.
There are about 200 tracked by
the data service DeepDAO
and they all have different goals.
Like collectively owning an NBA team,
a rare copy of the US Constitution,
or a future blockchain-based city.
So how exactly do DAOs work?
Why have they become a part
of Wyoming real estate?
And what risks come
with investing in them?
- DAO stands for decentralized
autonomous organization.
Think about a mutual fund,
which is an investment
product created by a company,
the company maintains it,
the company is responsible
for managing all the money,
for deciding what the
mutual fund's purpose is,
what its goal is.
- [Narrator] But unlike a mutual fund,
DAOs don't have a company
or any leader to make these decisions.
Instead, members pool money together
and decide as a group
how they want to spend it.
Usually once members buy in,
they receive a token, which
grants them voting rights.
All of the DAO's
functions are also written
into code on the blockchain.
- Think about an investment vehicle
where all the components
of the investment vehicle
are written into a piece
of software and launched,
and nobody actually owns it
and it runs out on its own.
- [Narrator] Unlike a
traditional corporate structure
where the company looks for
investors to raise money,
DAOs let people find them
through the internet.
- The real sort of
ingenious idea behind this
isn't necessarily that you come up
with some new way to make money.
It's that you've come up with a new way
to find investors.
- [Narrator] CityDAO became
the first DAO to own land
thanks to a new law in Wyoming
that went into effect last July.
The law recognizes DAOs as LLCs
and LLCs can own real estate.
- Wyoming passed this law
because Wyoming legislators
a couple of years ago decided
that blockchain could give the
state a competitive advantage
and they wanted to try
to attract blockchain-based businesses.
- [Narrator] Wyoming has
passed a number of laws
to make it easier for
blockchain-based companies
to operate out of the state,
one of which exempts
cryptocurrency from state tax.
Inspired by the Wyoming DAO law,
Scott Fitsimones started CityDAO
in the hopes that eventually people
could buy land instantaneously
and those transactions
would be transparent
for all to see on the blockchain.
- If you were to go want to buy
or build something on a piece
of land in Wyoming right now,
you would have to go to LoopNet,
you'd have to go explore
different pieces of land,
you'd have to go on Craigslist
and try to call people,
and work out a deal, sign some papers,
maybe mail something.
It would just be a very
cumbersome, tiresome process.
- [Narrator] Fitsimones says CityDAO
has raised around $7 million
from its membership since
it was founded last July.
Members include Brian Armstrong,
the co-founder of Coinbase,
and Vitalik Buterin, co-creator
of the Ethereum network.
To join CityDAO,
you have to buy a citizen NFT,
which currently sells
for about 0.4 Ethereum,
which is around $1,000.
Once you're a citizen,
you have the right to vote on proposals
and propose your own ideas.
- For example, we had citizens
already pass a proposal
to get drone footage of the land.
- [Narrator] In January,
CityDAO released a new batch
of NFTs for citizens to purchase.
Each one represents a lease
to a specific plot of land in Wyoming.
- So imagine CityDAO
LLC owns this property
but we basically encode a lease as an NFT
and say you have the
right to use this parcel,
build on this parcel.
- [Narrator] Fitsimones says they intend
to treat this parcel as a test run
and that they're already looking
at locations for their next purchase.
He says the next one will
be in a less remote area,
so citizens can have the option
to build on the land.
- Perhaps there's some future
where we start living there,
living close to each other,
building things on the land.
- [Narrator] He also says CityDAO
is looking into buying
land outside Wyoming.
- We would still use the Wyoming LLC
and technically, Wyoming
LLCs can own land anywhere
but there are certainly some nuances
to how that works.
- [Narrator] DAOs are still considered
an experimental business model,
even as awareness grows.
- I think DAOs are
going to remain limited.
I think the idea is very intriguing.
I think you will see a lot of
attempts at experimentation.
People are gonna try it
out, see where it fits
but I think for the time being,
it's gonna be really hard to do one
of these on a very, very large scale.
- [Narrator] One DAO that made headlines
in November was ConstitutionDAO.
It tried to buy a rare first edition copy
of the US Constitution,
raising over $40 million
in less than a week.
That's just one example of how DAOs
can raise a lot of capital very quickly.
But this also makes them
a big target for hacking.
- When you're doing this,
ultimately, everything
now becomes dependent
upon the software.
If it was not written well
and it collects a lot of money,
somebody's gonna figure
out a way to hack it,
and get into it.
I mean, even well-written
software programs
can be hacked.
- [Narrator] And because
most DAOs communicate
through the messaging platform Discord,
security there is a growing
area of concern as well.
On January 10th, someone hacked
into a CityDAO administrator's
account on Discord
and scammed some members
into sending them tens
of thousands of dollars.
Fitsimones said that after the incident,
CityDAO did a full review
and increased security
on its server.
He added that this type of attack
has been happening to several DAO servers.
A spokeswoman from Discord
says the company is working
to prevent scams by investing
significant resources
in education and tools
that protect its users.
The lack of a traditional
corporate structure
could also make it harder
for individual investors
to hold DAOs accountable
when it comes to fraud, scams and abuse.
- This is a very risky, very nascent space
and most of the people who are in it sort
of understand those risks
and are willing to take them.
- [Narrator] The SEC says it wants
to bring the digital currency market
under its investor protection framework.
Meanwhile, DAO enthusiasts like Fitsimones
are hopeful that DAOs will
improve and grow over time.
- Eventually, people will kind
of realize the existing system
of it takes a month to buy
a piece of land or property,
that will seem really crazy.
And I definitely imagine
more and more land
and assets coming onto the blockchain
and CityDAO being there when that happens
and helping make it all possible.
(pensive music)